Every week millions of people come online for the very first time and everyone, no matter where they live, what language they speak, or their level of digital literacy deserves an internet that was made for them. Google's Next Billion Users Initiative conducts research and builds products for everyone everywhere. Visit nextbillionusers.google to hear their stories. What follows is a story I produced at the behest of Google's next billion users initiative. They paid me to make it, but I still followed my own interests and talked to who I wanted
每周都有数以百万计的人第一次上网，无论他们住在哪里、说什么语言或数字素养水平如何，所有人都理应拥有一个为他们量身打造的互联网。Google 的“下一代十亿用户”计划（Next Billion Users Initiative）为全球各地的所有人开展研究并构建产品。请访问 nextbillionusers.google 听听他们的故事。接下来是我应 Google“下一代十亿用户”计划的要求制作的一个故事。他们付钱让我制作这个节目，但我依然遵循自己的兴趣，采访我想采访的人，
to, and produced the episode to be valuable and relevant to people interested in design. I actually really like the result, but they did pay me, and I want you to know that, because it matters. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We started with a typewriter. A mechanical key was struck. The type lever was pushed down. The type bar that corresponded to the key that was pressed rose up and slammed onto the ink ribbon in front of a piece of paper.
并制作出对关注设计的人有价值且相关的节目。我其实非常喜欢这个结果，但他们确实付了钱，我想让你知道这一点，因为这很重要。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们从打字机开始。一个机械按键被敲击。打字杆被向下推。与被按下的按键相对应的字锤升起，并猛击在纸张前面的色带上。
It was all very kinetic and satisfying. But there was a problem. With old typewriters, if he typed too fast, the typebars that were close together could crash into each other. So a man named Christopher Letham Sholes created a hack. Instead of all the letters being in an intuitive alphabetical order, he separated common pairs of keys and scattered them across the keyboard so their type bars wouldn't jam. The first six letters across the top row of Sholes typewriter for Q, W, E, R, T, W. Quirty.
这一切都非常具有动感且令人满足。但问题来了。在旧式打字机上，如果打字太快，靠得较近的字锤可能会撞击在一起。于是，一个名叫克里斯托弗·莱瑟姆·肖尔斯（Christopher Latham Sholes）的人发明了一种变通方法。他没有将所有字母按直观的字母顺序排列，而是将常见的键对分开并散布在键盘上，这样它们的字锤就不会卡住。肖尔斯打字机顶行的前六个字母是 Q、W、E、R、T、Y。QWERTY。
Type this gut so adept with this configuration that even when typewriter mechanics evolved way beyond the point of needing key separated, the layout stuck around. And then, define all adaptive logic completely the layout stuck around on the computer keyboard as well. Then we got so used to the Quarty keyboard as an input device. It stuck around on smartphones too, even though using a tiny digital keyboard is nothing any user experienced designer would design for smartphones if they were starting from scratch. But that's how evolution is. Unless there's overwhelming pressure to push us in a new direction, we stay on the same path.
打字员对这种配置非常熟练，以至于当打字机机械技术的发展远远超出了需要分开按键的阶段时，这种布局依然保留了下来。然后，完全违背自适应逻辑的是，这种布局也保留在了计算机键盘上。接着，我们对作为输入设备的 QWERTY 键盘习以为常。它也留在了智能手机上，尽管使用微小的数字键盘并不是任何有经验的用户体验设计师如果从头开始会为智能手机设计的方案。但进化就是这样。除非有压倒性的压力推动我们朝着新的方向发展，否则我们就会沿着同一条路走下去。
The Quarty keyboard becomes less and less useful over time, but it hangs around until all of its drawbacks accumulate and it hits an obstacle so big, so powerful that it cannot be steamrolled by history or habit. It hits India. For Indic languages, and those are languages from India and the Indians of continent. There are so many diacritical marks and asenders and desenders. Typing on a keyboard like that, I'm sure there have been numerous PhDs written on redesigning Indian keyboards because guess what? None of them work. That is awesome. Baki. I'm a UX director at Google with the next billion
随着时间的推移，QWERTY 键盘变得越来越没用，但它一直存在，直到它的所有缺点累积起来，并撞上了一个如此巨大、如此强大的障碍，以至于无法被历史或习惯压路机般碾压过去。它撞上了印度。对于印度语言（即来自印度和印度次大陆的语言），有那么多的附加符号、上伸字和下伸字。在这样的键盘上打字——我确信有无数博士论文都是关于重新设计印度键盘的，因为你猜怎么着？它们没有一个管用的。这太棒了。巴基。我是 Google“下一代十亿用户”团队的产品总监。NBU 计划肩负着一项使命。互联网增长的大部分实际上将发生在世界各地，即美国以外的地区，以及过去我们所知的发达市场之外的地区。这些术语我个人并不是很喜欢。关于增长遍及世界各地的理念，
users team. The NBU initiative is on a mission. The majority of the growth for the internet is actually going to happen around the world, places outside of the United States, and outside of what we have known in the past as being the developed markets. Those are terms that I'm not personally fond of. The idea of the growth being around the world,
我们必须了解世界各地的人们。因此，这个团队的核心正是了解世界各地的人们以及他们在上网时的需求，并专门为他们开发体验。并没有单一的“NBU 用户”。我的意思是，名字里就写得很清楚了。他们有十亿之多。但他们也分布在全球各地，不同的技术以不同的速度触及他们，这就产生了一个问题。因为就像 QWERTY 键盘一样，新技术是建立在旧技术的残骸之上的。如果“下一代十亿用户”对更古老的上代技术没有任何经验，那么跨越到新设备就需要跨越越来越宽的鸿沟。我们习惯的许多隐喻，都因为我们过去的经历而深深地根植于我们心中……对不对？这与浏览网页并不完全一样。即使是专门为智能手机深思熟虑考虑的操作，对于新用户来说也可能是一个挑战。
we have to understand people around the world. And so this team is really based on understanding people around the world and their needs as they come online and developing experiences specifically for them. There is no one single NBU user. I mean, it's right there in the name. There's a billion of them. But they're also spread across the globe and different technology
以来自墨西哥城的克劳迪娅（Claudia）为例。或者甚至是墨西哥城郊外的一个小镇。好吧，来自德卢卡的克劳迪娅。她刚接触互联网，是第一次上网，或者甚至只是见过科技产品。它一直在她身边。
has reached them at different rates, which creates a problem. Because just like the Quirty Keyboard, technology is built on the carcasses of older technology. And if the next Billions user has no experience with the last older technology, the leap to a new device involves getting across a wider and wider chasm. A lot of the metaphors that we're used to are ones that are deeply ingrained from us in us because of what we'veasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of the ecstasy of right? It's not the same as floating a page. Even actions that are thoughtfully considered specifically for a smartphone can be a challenge for a new user.
她的朋友或亲戚使用过这种技术。她总是感到有一点焦虑，觉得“这不适合我”。而这正是像 Google 这样的公司所不希望看到的，因为毫无疑问，他们希望克劳迪娅成为客户，而创造不会让她感到压力的产品和体验是实现这一目标的关键。
Take as a hypothetical example, Claudia from Mexico City. Or even a town outside of Mexico City. Okay, Claudia from Deluca. She's new to the internet, and she's coming online for the first time, or even just has seen technology. It's been around her.
如果他们现在失去了她，他们可能永远失去她。然而，她还是鼓起勇气，开始使用朋友的手机、伴侣的手机，甚至可能是她儿子的手机。只是为了开始尝试。她遇到的问题可谓不计其数。她第一次拿起手机。解锁手机意味着什么？我的意思是，它没有按键。她看到别人在滑动，所以她也尝试滑动。
She's had friends or relatives that have used that technology. And she's always felt a little bit of anxiety, of this is not for me. And this is something that coming to like Google doesn't want because make no mistake. They want Claudia as a customer, and making products and experiences that don't struts her out is a key to this.
于是你开始往各个方向滑动，因为这只是退出手机的一种方式。滑动、点击。看起来很棒，但没有任何意义。因此，你和我通过反复摸索而逐渐理解和领会的这些隐喻，因为我们拥有那种隐式自信，而她却没有这种自信。
If they lose her now, they may lose her forever. But yet she pushes herself and she either starts using a friend's phone or using her spouse's phone or using, you know, maybe even her son's phone. Just to start experimenting. The types of the problems that she runs into are numerous. She picks up the phone for the first time. What does it mean to unlock a phone? I mean, it doesn't have a key. She's seeing people swipe, so she tries swiping.
为了让事情变得更复杂，她需要使用手机的方式可能并不是为第一批用户进行设计的那些人所预料到的。因此，因为别人告诉她要向右滑动，她就向右滑动了。这会解锁手机或诸如此类的操作，向上滑动并输入密码，因为其中许多手机实际上是被锁定的。因为它们是多用户设备，多个人在共用同一台设备。而这仅仅是为了将手机解锁。在此之后，她还必须应付手机上可能由多个用户的任何人加载的所有单个应用程序。
And so you start swiping in every direction, because that's just the way to exit phones. Wiping tapping. It looks great, but it doesn't mean anything. So these metaphors that you and I have come to appreciate and understand, because of the fact that we've learned through trial and error, but still have that implicit confidence, she doesn't have that confidence.
从那以后，事情就会呈指数级变得更加复杂且难以预测。这并不是说有些设计不管是谁在用都能直接起作用。我们来看看 Google 地图，对吧？还有某种程度上的照片应用，双指捏合和缩放，这是你在两岁小孩身上都能看到的设备操作之一。正因为如此，你会意识到这种直觉是根深蒂固的。关于这一点，你看到两岁小孩在设备上这样做，正因为如此，你会意识到这种直觉是根深蒂固的。事情的关键在于，你抓住某个东西然后向外拉，
To complicate matters further, the ways she needs to use this phone may not be the ones anticipated by the people designing for the first-boying users. And so she swipes right because she's told to. It unlocks the phone or whatever it might be, swipes up been types in the password because many of these phones are actually locked. Because they're multi-user devices, people are using multiple people are using the same device. And this is just to get to the point of getting the phone unlocked. After this, she has to contend with all the individual apps that may have been loaded
或者你推某个东西然后把它推开。这是一种非常体贴的手势，我对此非常感激。我不知道是谁想出了这个点子。但总体而言，像捏合和缩放这样似乎超越年龄和文化界限的用户体验设计非常少。因此，阿西夫（Asif）和 NBU 计划的工作就是建立在实证研究的基础之上来设计产品。
on there by anyone of the multiple users of the phone. And it just gets exponentially more complicated and unpredictable from there. That's not to say that there aren't some designs that just work, no matter who is using them. Let's look at Google Maps, right? And photos to a certain extent, pinching and zooming, it's one of those things that you see two-year-olds doing on devices. And because of that, you realize the intuition is deep. The thing about it is that you see two-year-olds doing on devices, and because of that, you realize the intuition is deep. The thing about it is that you're grabbing on to something and you're pulling out,
它始于交谈、提出问题以及与他们所为之设计的人们共同生活。关键在于倾听。我们走在班加罗尔的街头，为我们正在开发的一款支付产品进行小微企业调研。和我在一起的一位产品负责人观察了整体体验，并试图在我们当天进行的采访过程中进行总结，然后他说：“我们需要将他们的账本数字化。”他正确且中肯地指出，一天结束时，店主会坐在笔记本前算账，必须盘点整个库存，确保他或她清楚地了解有多少货物售出了、自己赚了多少钱，等等。
or you're pushing on something and you're pushing it away. That's just a very thoughtful gesture, which I'm extremely appreciative of. I don't know who came up with it. But overall, there are very few user-experienced designs like Pinging and Zooming that seem to transcend age and cultural boundaries. So the work of ASIF and the NBU Initiative is to design things on a foundation of empirical research.
对我们来说，“数字化”是思考如何增加价值的一种如此简单的方式，因为我们知道如何进行数字化，知道如何为其创建用户界面，知道如何存储该数据并将其调取回来。我们知道如何进行所有计算。但当他们带着帮助这些店主经营生意的想法回来时，却得到了一个意想不到的反应。他们拒绝了。他们说：“我目前做事的方式没有任何问题。”
It starts with talking, asking questions, and living around the people they're designing for. The key is to listen. We're walking down the streets of Bangalore doing small, medium business research for a payments product we were working on. And one of the product matters I was with looked at the general experience and was trying to summarize over the course
我一天结束时只需花五分钟。实际上，这并不是一个需要解决的问题，不是吗？在规模足够小的生意中，两件商品售出，两件商品进货，我知道我需要订购一件，这就万事大吉了。这并不是说账本软件——实际上在印度以及我们研究过小微企业的其他地方，有许多账本软件已经成功了——这并不是说账本软件不会成功。只是 Google 团队将事情电脑化的常见倾向并不一定是正确的答案。
of the interviews we had done for the day and said, we need to digitize their ledger. He noted rightfully, correctly, that at the end of the day, the merchant would sit down with his notebook and do some math and have to go through the entire inventory and make sure he understood where she understood this is exactly how much has gone out of the store, this is how much I've made and so
因为它剥夺了人们实际处理日常任务方式中的简单与美好。接下来还有更多精彩内容。大多数第一次使用互联网的人都是通过手机而不是电脑上网的。他们经常与家人和朋友共用设备，而且他们更喜欢语音和视觉，而不是打字和阅读。正是这些真知灼见帮助 Google 构建了更有用、更具包容性的产品。
on. And for us digitizing is such an easy way to think about how we can add value because we know how to digitize, we know how to create the UI for it, we know how to store that data and to bring it back. We know how to do all the computation. But when they came back with the ideas to help these merchants with their business, they got an unexpected response. They pooped it. They said, I have no problem with the way that I currently do things.
访问 nextbillionusers.google 探索相关研究。遭人唾弃的反犹太主义者亨利·福特（Henry Ford）说过：“如果我问人们想要什么，他们会说一匹更快的马。”这是一个用来证明福特天才的轶事，而且确实有几分道理。如果你去问那些对汽车毫无概念的人，他们会告诉你他们想要一匹更快的马。但他们通常不会告诉你的是，他们根本不想要马。他们不想变得更有生产力。
It takes me five minutes at the end of the day. And in reality, this wasn't a problem that needed solving, is it? On a small enough business where two things go out and two things come in, I know I need to order one and I should be good to go. It's not to say that a ledger software, there are actually many in India and beyond where we study small businesses that had succeeded. It's not to say that a ledger piece of software won't succeed. It's just that the Google team's common inclination towards making things computerized was not necessarily the right answer.
他们想玩游戏、和朋友聊天、调情。他们愿意放弃吃饭。他们愿意打三班倒——比如早班、中班和晚班，只为了能得到这点额外的数据流量，好跟某个女孩聊天。这就是帕亚尔·奥罗拉（Payal Aurora）。我是鹿特丹伊拉斯姆斯大学的教授。
Because it removes the simplicity and beauty from the way that people actually approach their day-to-day tasks. There's more to the story after this. The majority of people using the internet for the first time do so on mobile, not on a computer. They often share devices with family and friends, and they prefer voice and visuals over typing and reading. It's insights like these that help Google build more helpful and inclusive products.
我是一名数字人类学家，著有多本书籍。最新的一本是《下一代十亿用户》。尽管她的书和专业知识也关于“下一代十亿用户”，但她并不为 Google 工作。在研究印度、巴西和非洲国家的上网用户的这 10 年里，帕亚尔亲身经历了一些公司和机构引入技术，认为穷国的人民会采用这些技术来提高生产力、摆脱贫困，简而言之，让他们的生活变得更好。
Visit nextbillionusers.google to explore the research. The deplorable anti-Semite Henry Ford said, if I asked people what they wanted, they would have said a faster horse. It's an anecdote to demonstrate Ford's genius, and it does make some sense. If you ask people who have no concept of an automobile, they will tell you that they want a faster horse. But what they often don't tell you is that they don't want a horse at all. They do not want to be more productive.
但一次又一次，世界各地的人们表明，他们想要让生活变得更好的方式是通过快乐和休闲。她参与的第一个项目是在 2000 年代初的班加罗尔。当时有这样一些站点，看起来像个 ATM 机，但它实际上是一个信息 ATM 机，为了解医疗保健信息的女性而设，为了解农作物价格以便更有竞争力的农民而设，年轻人可以
They want to play games, chat with friends, and flirt. They're willing to give up their meals. They're willing to work three shifts in like work morning, noon, and night just so they can get this extra data so they can like chat some girl. This is Paiyalla Aurora. I'm a professor at Arasmus University of Rotterdam.
学习并补充英语技能，因为那是通往社会流动性的途径。这些站点设立在所有这些不同的地方。在基本上是唯一的一家餐馆里，他们有一个屏幕，信息会不间断地滚动播放，这是一个滚动显示区域天气数据和有用信息的电传打字机纸带。我们有这些小货车，把技术带到村民们的各个偏远角落，说服大家：“嘿，你猜怎么着，有个东西叫互联网，它棒极了。”你会爱上它的。
I'm a digital anthropologist and I've authored a number of books. The reason one being the next billion users. Even though her book and expertise is also about the next billion users, she does not work for Google. Over the 10 years of researching users coming online in India, Brazil, and countries in Africa, Payal has had first-hand experience with companies and agencies introducing technology with the notion that it will be adopted by people in poorer countries to make themselves more productive, to get themselves out of poverty, in short, to make their lives better.
你应该去看看。还有这些社区信息中心，你应该去，它们就在镇上，对吧？六个月后，人们开始给我们打电话：“哦，太好了，电影车要来了”，因为我们希望让村民对他们从未听闻的事物感到兴奋的因素。所以我们
But over and over again, people all over the globe have shown that the way that they want to make their lives better is through pleasure and leisure. The first project she was involved with was in Bangalore in the early 2000s. So there were these stations, like it looks like an ATM, but it was really an ATM for information, for, you know, really an ATM for information, for women to check healthcare information, for farmers to check crop prices so they can be more competitive, churn could
承诺给他们播放好莱坞电影——也就是南方宝莱坞的电影。于是他们会盛装打扮，大家都觉得：“哦，今晚放映会有某种车开来给我们放电影，然后在中间插播一些奇怪的技术内容，对吧？”然后我们就可以继续看电影了。它变得异常受欢迎。事实上，
learn and supplement the English skills because that was the pathway to mobility. And there was stationed on all these different places. And in what was basically the only restaurant, they had a screen where information would just flow nonstop, a ticker tape of regional weather data and useful information. And we had these little vans where we would take technologies to all these further corners of the villagers and convince people that, hey, guess what, there is something called the internet and it's amazing. And you're going to love it.
我要说的是，我们的传奇之处就在于我们成了“电影车”。你知道，每当我们向他们展示互联网时，他们的反应都是：“好吧，上厕所时间到了”，也就是中场休息，大家纷纷走开。这让他们感到无比无聊。这并不是说这不是有用的信息。实际上，这是非常重要的信息。其中很大一部分集中在为农民提供农作物价格。但农民们并没有抱有幻想，
And you should check it out. And there's these community information centers, which you should go to, which is in the town, right? Six months down the line, people started calling us, oh, great, there's a movie band coming because the factors that we wanted to get villagers to get excited about something that they had never heard of. So we
认为掌握这些信息就能真正解决他们的问题。这是我在许多不同的语境中一次又一次听到的说法。他们会听。这个系统是固定死板的。就像是：“你可以告诉我城市里的价格是多少。首先，我不是白痴。”
promised to show them Hollywood, which is the body of the South movie. So they would get dressed up and they would all like, oh evening show there's some van that comes and shows us a movie and then interrupts us with some weird technology stuff, right? And then we can go resume and watch the movie again. And it became extraordinary popular. In fact,
我知道我的售价远远低于市场价。我只是别无选择，好吧？由于基础设施和配送机制落后，他们知道我负担不起返回农场的费用。因此货物必须卖掉，而且价格是固定的，他们知道存在农民供应，无论你认为存在什么信息赤字，我们都必须把东西卖掉。因此，我们实际上设计了整个项目，其基础是一种居高临下的世界观，即这些农民的贫困主要是由于信息赤字，只要我们
I would say that's our legacy is that we were the movie bands. And you know, whenever we show them the internet, they're like, okay, toilet break, you know, the interval, off we go. And it was extraordinary boring for them. And it's not that it was not useful information. It was actually very important information. A lot of it was centered on providing crop prices to farmers. But the farmers had no illusions
能引入正确的信息，他们就会取得进步。女性健康信息也是如此。这里有关于如何减少生育孩子的健康信息，你的反应是：“当然，我可以少生孩子，并不是说我不知道自己可以使用避孕药具。”问题在于：我丈夫会戴吗？而且我生儿子了吗？如果没有，我最好继续生孩子，直到生个男孩为止，对吧？
that having this information would actually solve their problems. This is something I have heard again and again in many different contexts. Is that they'll listen. The system is fixed. It's like, you can tell me what the prices are in the city. Firstly, I'm not an idiot.
这其中很大一部分是社会的、文化的和情境的，但有一点是一致的。在各个群体、各个种姓制度中都能引起完全共鸣的，是他们对娱乐的热爱，因为生活确实很无聊。你有很多空闲时间。你知道的，如果你不种地，你需要某种形式的娱乐，
I know I'm selling at bay below market price. I just don't have a dumb choice, okay? Because of the poor infrastructures and the delivery mechanisms, they know I can't afford to go back to my farm. So the goods have to be sold and there's a fixed price and they know there's a farmer supply and we have to sell regardless of what you think is information deficit. So we actually designed an entire program based on a condescending worldview that it was basically the information deficit of these farmers that led to their poverty and if only we
而我们变得异常受欢迎，因为这些信息 ATM 机变成了游戏机亭。孩子们简直爱死它们了。他们把它们当成游戏机，其中许多社区信息中心变成了友谊咖啡馆。这些用户在想象中对这些场所进行的重新构架，恰恰表明了这些才是得到满足的真正实际需求。而不是我们以为他们需要的需求。正是这种由于不了解用户需求而导致的灾难性结果，
could introduce the right information they would progress right. It was the same story for women's health care information. Here's health care information you know about how you could have less children you're like sure I can have less children not You're like, sure, I can have less children, not that I don't know that I can wear contraceptives. There's a question, will my husband wear it? And have I produced a son as yet? If not, I better keep producing those babies until I get a boy, right?
才促成了 Google 的 NBU 计划等项目的诞生。他们的办公室设在这些国家内部，让他们能够花时间融入他们试图服务的人们的家庭中，亲身体验他们的需求和焦虑。这种将研究重点高度集中于具有特定需求的一个群体的益处之一，就是当你为最极端的用例设计产品时，
So much of it was social, cultural, and situational, but one thing was consistent. What is completely resonant across demographics, across caste systems, was their love for being entertained, because it does get boring. You have a lot of downtime. You know, if you're not farming, and you need some form of entertainment,
你最终可以把事情做得对所有人都更好。再次请出阿扎·巴基（Aza Bakia）。“下一代十亿用户”国家的人们有时使用的手机并不是最新型号。它们不是处理器最快的。我们早期发现的严重影响他们体验的问题之一，是设备上缺乏存储空间。对于我们来说，这就像是，是的，
and we became extra-n became extraordinary popular because these 8 hems of information became gaming kiosks. Kids just loved it. They were like using it as a gaming station and a lot of these community information centers became friendship cafes. Just the fact that they were you know reframed in the imagination of these users showcase that these were re-framed in the imagination of these users, showcased that these were the real actual needs that were being met. And not the ones we believe they needed. These kinds of disastrous results that came from not understanding the needs of the users
好吧，我可以找到并删除几个文件。但是？但对他们来说，实际情况要严重得多，因为由设备缺乏存储空间所产生的焦虑是难以承受的。由于缺乏存储空间——他们并未将其归咎于存储空间不足——并且由于他们对这些设备的工作原理缺乏深入了解，这开始导致他们的手机死机、应用程序变慢、无法接收亲人的照片、无法分享他们关心的音乐。许多事情都无法正常进行，
is what led to projects like the NBU Initiative at Google, whose offices are embedded in the countries where they can spend time in the homes of the people they're trying to serve, and they can experience their needs and anxieties first hand. And one of the benefits of this intense research focus on one group with specific needs is that when you design things for the most extreme use cases,
全都是因为他们设备上的存储空间问题。因此，如果设备的设计没有考虑到让经验有限的用户能够处理他们的存储空间问题，他们就会去别处寻求帮助。而这种帮助可能并不正规。他们会回到购买手机的手机店寻求帮助。我们见过这样的情况：手机店老板会拿过手机放到一边，
you can end up making things better for everyone. Here's Aza Bakia again. People in next-planned user countries sometimes have phones that are not the latest models. They're not the fastest processors. One of the problems that we found early on severely impacted their experience was a lack of storage under device. And this is something that for us, it's like, yeah,
让他们一个小时后再来，说：“你的手机拿回去”，并收取更新手机所需的 40 卢比费用。我们还见过这样的情况：他们被迫重置整个设备，人们丢失了信息，丢失了上面的所有东西，但设备的运行性能显然又恢复正常了。当你与云端数据建立的关系与我们过去几年受到的训练方式不同时，这种损失可能会具有毁灭性的打击。例如，如果他们想要一些照片，他们甚至会付费请专业摄影师拍摄全家福，然后把照片保存下来。所以他们使用它的方式就像是在打印出来一样。因此，
OK, I can find, delete a few files. But? But in actuality for them, it was a lot more, because that anxiety that's produced by what is caused by a lack of storage on their device is untenable. Because of the lack of storage, which they don't attribute to lack of storage, and because they don't have the deep knowledge of how these devices work, start freezing their phone, start slowing down applications, prevent them from receiving pictures of their loved ones, prevent them from sharing music that they care about. So many things are just not happening
奇怪的是，手机上的数字副本对他们来说真的就像是一张冲印照片。他们会正式打扮一番，而且并不认为它是用完即弃、转瞬即逝的东西。因此，他们会保留某些真正赋予意义的东西。为了管理旧手机上的存储空间，“下一代十亿用户”所感受到的这种紧张感促使 Google 推出了一款名为“文件”（Files）的产品，以帮助人们管理和释放空间。我们最早看到使用量巨幅增长的国家中，有一些是意大利、美国，等等。因此，这款针对印度和巴西进行了定性研究的产品，最终风靡了全世界。
because of storage on their device. So if the devices are not designed in such a way that the user with limited experience can deal with their storage problem, they seek help elsewhere. And that help may not be on the level. They go back to the mobile phone shop where they bought their phone and they ask for help. And we've seen instances where these mobile shop owners will take the phone and put it to the side,
但从根本上讲，在人类的层面上，我们所有人都有问题。我们希望优化我们的设备。我们希望能够让我们的设备变得更好，以便我们能够更多地享受生活。这与通用设计的原则相同，就像我们为坐轮椅的人修建无障碍坡道，同时也会注意到它同样有利于推婴儿车的健全人或任何在城市中出行的人。这无疑是一个好处。为具有极端用例的人群进行设计，可以创造出更易于使用、
and bite them back after an hour and say, here's your phone back, and charge them the 40 rupees that it costs to update their phone. We've seen instances where they're just forced and reset the entire device, and people lose their information, they lose everything on it, but devices are obviously performed better again. This loss can be particularly devastating when your relationship with your data on the cloud is different from how we've been trained in the last few years. For example, if they want to have some photographs, they will even pay to have a professional photographer, take the full family photograph, and then they keep that. So they use it as if they're printing it out. So the
更简单且对所有人都有更高实用性的产品。然而，为需求与已经上网的人不同的人进行设计，具有内在的道德价值，走到人群中去并为他们服务本身就是一种美德。但是，有新人加入进来，以全新的视角和不同的挑战看待现状，并真正质疑我们是如何走到这一步的，
weird thing is a digital copy on a mobile phone is really like a print for them. They formally dress up and they don't look at it as disposable transient. So they hold onto certain things which really make a give meaning. This tension that the next Boeing users felt about managing storage on old phones led Google to launch a product called Files to help people manage and free up space. And some of the early countries where we saw immense uptake, Italy, the United States, right? And so this is where a product that was built for India and Brazil in terms of the
这是极其宝贵的。就像我们一直依赖的用于智能手机的微小数字键盘一样，全新的视角和不同的挑战让我们质疑我们是如何走到这一步的。就像我们一直依赖的用于智能手机的微小数字键盘一样，“下一代十亿用户”可能已经觉得很多事情一团糟，但就像青蛙被慢慢加热的水煮熟一样，我们只是没有注意到或者已经习惯了。直到“下一代十亿用户”和我们一起跳进锅里并质问：这水怎么这么烫？这一期的 99% Invisible 特别节目由我——罗曼·马斯制作，音乐由肖恩·雷尔（Sean Rell）提供。你可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上找到各种其他故事。
qualitative research having been done in those two countries took off all over the world. But fundamentally at a human level, we all have problems. We want to optimize our devices. We want to be able to make our devices better so that we can enjoy ourselves more. This is the same principle of universal design that is touted when we put in curb cuts for people in wheelchairs and notice that it also benefits able-bodied people pushing strollers or really anyone navigating the city. And this is a benefit to be sure. Designing for people with extreme use cases creates products that can be easier to use,
构建有用且具有包容性的产品是一项全球性的工作。Google 正在致力于扩大获取信息的渠道，并构建帮助人们释放全球经济机遇的产品。他们邀请技术构建者利用其开发和设计工具来创造更具包容性的产品。访问 nextbillionusers.google 探索这些工具。创造更具包容性的产品。访问 nextbillionusers.google 探索这些工具。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
more simple, and have greater utility for everyone. However, designing for people with different needs than those already online has inherent moral value, meeting people where they are and serving them is enough of a virtue in and of itself. But it is so valuable to have someone new come in, look at the way things are with fresh eyes and different challenges, and really question
更简单，对每个人都更有用。然而，为与现有网民需求不同的人进行设计具有内在的道德价值，因地制宜并为他们服务本身就是一种美德。但有新人加入，带着全新的视角和不同的挑战审视现状，并真正质疑
how we got to know. Just like the tiny digital critical board we kept relying on for our smartphones, fresh eyes and different challenges, and really question how we got to know. Just like the tiny digital critical board we kept relying on for our smartphones, many things probably already sucked for the first billion users, but like a frog being boiled as someone slowly turns up the heat, we just didn't notice or got used to it. That is until the next billion users gets in the pot with us and asks, Why is this water so hot? This special episode of 99% of Asible was produced by me, Roman Mars, with music by Sean Raell. You can find all kinds of other stories on our website, 99pi.org.
我们是如何变成这样的。就像我们一直依赖智能手机的微型数字关键面板一样，全新的视角和不同的挑战，真正质疑我们是如何了解这一切的。就像我们一直依赖智能手机的微型数字关键面板一样，对于前十亿用户来说，很多事情可能已经很糟糕了，但就像温水煮青蛙一样，随着水温慢慢升高，我们只是没有注意到或者习惯了。直到下一亿用户和我们一起进入锅里，问：为什么这水这么烫？这期《99%无形》特别节目由我（罗曼·马尔斯）制作，音乐由肖恩·拉尔创作。您可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上找到各种其他故事。
Building the helpful and inclusive products is a global effort. Google is working to expand access to information and build products that help people unlock economic opportunity around the world. And they're inviting tech builders to use their development and design tools to create more inclusive products. Visit nextbillionusers.google to explore the tools. more inclusive products. Visit nextbillionusers.google to explore the tools. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
打造有用且包容的产品是一项全球性的努力。谷歌正致力于扩大信息获取渠道，并打造帮助世界各地的人们释放经济机遇的产品。他们邀请科技开发者使用其开发和设计工具来打造更具包容性的产品。访问 nextbillionusers.google 探索这些工具。打造更具包容性的产品。访问 nextbillionusers.google 探索这些工具。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。